so we are here today with Professor Alan
Catania and Alan is a physician
practicing internist at the Brigham he's
also a lawyer and we are going to talk
about the law and regulation and how
these tools are used to help assure and
improve healthcare quality Alan welcome
thank you so much for coming
it's a pleasure to be here so Alan I
want to start off sort of taking a big
step back and we're going to begin by
thinking about the the legal and
regulatory structure in the US what role
does the law play in assuring that when
I go see a doctor when somebody comes to
a hospital that the quality of that
health care is it's at least halfway
good what what what can the law do in
that respect so I think there's actually
three ways that the law helps assure
that we have high quality or save care
in this country okay
the first is regulation States or the
federal government sets minimum
standards for which a practitioner must
meet or a hospital must meet if it wants
to operate the second is for liability
system now practice that's a system of
accountability we can talk about more
than a second and then the third is when
it actually creates financial incentives
or penalties for hospitals and
physicians and other providers with
regard to how they behave in what they
do and the ACA is a classic example of
that okay so they're all really
important let's take each one of them
one at a time if you don't want sure so
let's start with regulation why do you
mean regulation give me a couple of
examples of the kinds of things that we
do in the US on regulation and what what
do they have to do with quality so I
think the classic example of regulation
that people think of is you need to have
a license to practice you so I think the
idea there is that if a doctor has been
a practice medicine he or she needs
talking that minimum training
requirements so the ideas on people out
there practicing we know that they at
least have a floor or base baseline
level of knowledge that everybody will
meet and who sets those standards of
what is a minimum level of baseline it
can vary in how they're set sometimes
they're set by the states themselves or
sometimes they're set by the state's
working with the relevant
kind of professional body working with
them to figure out what the standard
should look like okay and so the state
says if you're going to be a practicing
internist or do be a physician in the
state of Massachusetts in the United
States you need to have what gone to
medical school done certain amount of
post medical school training correct I
believe in most states it's either one
or two years so that you don't have to
finish a full residency to do it I think
in some states it's really one year and
then you can go and get a license to
practice for other professionals in
health care beyond physicians who end up
usually having to meet a licensing
requirement so it can include nurses
pharmacists physical therapists I think
those are all examples of people who did
have a license or passed some kind of
certification before they can practice
got it so almost everybody who touches a
patient sounds like in the u.s. in most
states
maybe all states you need some sort of a
license before you can before you can
get involved in Pishin correct okay so
we've talked about licensing as one set
of regulatory mechanisms what else is
there from a regulatory kind of thing
what about for hospitals what about for
others for hospitals there are
regulations that are set up around fire
safety for example is subject to
regulation or how safe the building is
is it up to codes that it won't come
coming down on people so all of that is
subject to regulation just as is the
airflow pattern in healthcare
institutions because sometimes you need
isolation precautions and things like
that yeah so all of that is subject to
regulation in some states things like
nursing staffing ratios are also subject
to regulation if you look at hospitals
in America if I wanted tomorrow to go
and build a hospital set it up and run
it to take care of patients what
specific to health care would I have to
do to make sure I could run a hospital
in Boston tomorrow and that's a great
question I'm not sure I know exactly all
the people you'd have to interact with
to make this happen
I imagine you'd have to work at least
with the Department of Public Health
because they also issue regulations
around what hospitals need to do okay so
we have Department of Public Health
what about regulators sort of beyond
things like Medicare right Medicare is
the biggest payer of health care in
America do they get involved in figuring
out like what hospitals their patients
can go to or all
or can a Medicare patient go to any
Hospital he or she wants
so one Medicare does get involved in
regulation for you to receive payment
from the federal government for Medicare
patients know there are actually what
they call conditions of participation
that you have to meet okay
one of one of the common conditions of
participation that people talk about is
you don't have to be reviewed by the
government accredited by the government
so they can say you're up to snuff with
regard to all the standards they've said
or you can face or you can undergo
what's called Joint Commission
accreditation where the Joint Commission
comes in and reviews you okay I think as
long as you need all of Medicare's
conditions of participation Medicare
patients can come in to pretty much any
hospital that they want in the
government will pay now there are
certain regulations that can constrain
the flow of patients but those don't
have to do with regulation on the
hospital and they actually deal with it
on the patient ends because some
patients can sign up for either what
they call traditional Medicare which
allows you to go where you want or you
can choose to sign up for with something
that they call Medicare Advantage which
puts you in a capitated or a managed
care plan which can restrict your
movement so fundamentally if you're
thinking about who's regulating the
quality of hospital care Medicare has an
important role to play in asking you to
get either Joint Commission Commission
accreditation or getting transition
directly correct and they use the power
of the purse to get people to follow
those standards because the Medicare
business often tends to comprise a
significant share of most hospitals